[Music]
[Music]
and that ladies and gentlemen is the
best way we've ever opened up a
simulation show I am so happy to have
Paulo let joining us on simulation we'll
be talking about filmmaking talking
about art really excited man think yeah
likewise
super pumped all right let's get the mic
stand out of the way for now and later
we will bring it back on the set coming
over you it doesn't matter
remove the mic stand all right
dope you're dope all right so Paul Oh
mister we've made some cool videos
together yeah dude
ah has if you haven't seen those videos
yet go give them a look I'm really
excited to continue making good art with
Paul the rich short video is like 30 60
second videos and they've been a very
thought-provoking have really enjoyed
them Paul is an interdisciplinary artist
musician photographer filmmaker he's got
some surrealism he's got some DIY energy
some design energy it's like this guy is
going to unpack how to creatively
unleash energy into the planet yeah it's
kind of just I guess that's just the
everyday huh so if you also if you don't
follow paul on instagram go do it
immediately hit links in the bio super
incredible Instagram news feed every
single day and also stories every single
day they're just lit go and follow
immediately thank you you're super
welcome all right so let's let's start
by of course you already showed us
incredible guitar skills he's got two
albums on his website you can go look at
them they are called white birch and dog
God's will the doll guys is the is the
ALP is the band punk name oh yes doll
guides so doll gods is
the band the first project I've done the
first I guess like like officially
released recorded project I've done and
that that album is called summer head
and it's it's a seven track like sort of
like alt punk surf Punk kind of kind of
vibe a little bit old-school like a
little bit of a little bit of Devo in
there I guess a little bit of you know
like Violent Femmes and like riot girl
music and stuff like that like shout and
lead female vocalist Ally Carrie you
like the Pixies
I love the Pixies yeah monkey gone to
heaven and so I was on my head the other
day you know of God if the devil is six
then seven sorry
god no no penance by all means I love
that song yeah must God to heaven just a
year ago Ron you want to show that on
the Oh certainly it's on the TV right
now to talk about it and I'll get it on
your screen all right thank you
so the the in will continue pulling up
cool things like this to showcase
because here you have a it's coming the
nd ice coming on to the studio screen
all right so the what's interesting here
is you actually you collaborated on this
with Ally Kerry who did vocals and
guitar yeah and then Cal and Clark yeah
did bass and production yeah so
Oh Erin white did drums as well so this
now do you guys and we're gonna get to
all this but I'm curious do you guys
still are they in Burlington
or are they today so part of the reason
that we had to record this was so right
so right before it got released they um
they actually like they moved to the
Boston area where they still are and
they're still making music they're
actually they're together they're
they're a couple and they're two of my
best friends and Ally is actually the
the lead in my film the factory she
yeah she's in the Dead Souls music video
longtime collaborator also
multidisciplinary she has she's mostly
doing music these days but she's an
educator see that's her right there
mm-hmm
that's her right here yeah and Aaron is
the and this is one of his three films
that's on his website yes the factory
the shadow and the Dead Souls yeah well
I've got more than that the Dead Souls I
count as more like just you know music
video cuz you know it's supplementary to
someone else's music which is and then I
guess the other full film I would say is
cockroach my way right but the other
ones that are kind of floating around
there and some are hidden actually some
you have to like float over them and see
that they're a video there's stuff I
haven't like shown anyone they're like
sit there Easter eggs hidden on my
website oh this is the factory right
here what do you do a job there Alan I
was getting the Instagram ready yeah you
gotta you gotta check out his films as
well so the now now okay let's let's
start here because you're obviously
combining a ridiculous amount of this is
on 16 millimeter film this is it's a
silent film it's it's totally different
than everything else we see on the
internet today yeah thank you thank you
I'll take it okay yeah that's the point
of life isn't it yeah [ __ ] different
than everyone exactly when that was
actually one of the main goals of the
film I wanted to I mean it's not coming
out of nowhere like there are a lot of
filmmakers that I'm harkening back to
from like there's a lot of Czech
filmmakers and like Eastern Europe in
Eastern European filmmakers that's what
60s and 70s that I'm calling back to
people that
you know people my age don't tend to
know about unless they went to film
school art school and even then maybe
didn't even touch on them at all so it's
like you know when an aesthetic is like
come on there's a chance to end go on
quote unquote but out of I guess like
the public eye and like you know it's
out of popular iconography you know then
you can and there's a there's an
opportunity to reuse it and recycle it
and to take it and have it means
something new but like you know kind of
harken back to the way they made it the
things that they might have meant that
that period of time you know and so I
guess one is your intention with it my
intention was to do just that to make
something that no one else to make
something that was dissimilar from
things that I had seen while also being
well also kind of just you know being
similar enough to the things I like I
guess I wanted to the main goal I guess
of the factory was a test of myself and
I used to be a big perfectionist you
know what I mean I used to really worry
about the finite details of my work and
worry about you know everything coming
out exactly right just the way I wanted
it in my head like oh it's got to be
perfect
and working making such a big project on
film was sort of a way of coping with
that because with film your
perfectionism
yeah with film it can totally completely
destroy itself it can totally things
shots might not come out at all the way
you want them to you know maybe you
expose it and you make sure you meet her
and you make sure everything's looking
nice but then you see the shot and
you're like that's not you know that's
totally different especially with a
Bolex - and which was the type of camera
I was using their old home video cameras
and for instance you have to crank it by
hand
you only get a shot that could it the
longest it could last is 30 seconds on
like normal speeds on normal frame rates
and it comes with a lot of limitations
this part was crazy when I had that
filing cabinet that was stacked yeah
world's tallest filing cabinet
by the way the reason it's fun I didn't
know this while I was making it but the
reason they built it was because they
there was for a period of time they were
thinking of taking that section of town
and making a four-lane highway right
through the town so what they did was
they built that structure there of just
like this anti like corporatist yeah
piece of art like just a giant filing
cabinet as a way of like they wanted to
do a landmark so they were like what
hasn't been done and they did a world's
tallest stack of filing cabinets put it
right up and that was like now it's a
landmark now it's like a visitor's it's
a thing for tourists to go look at now
there is no tourists I've never really
seen tourists go look at it but it
worked nonetheless and now it's just
kind of like dingy graffiti to up a
thing and I just love the image it's so
good the way the way you captured it is
it's it's awesome nobody again
Burlington has what 250,000 people
Burlington vermis ten million right now
Vermont has 250,000 people like 150k
Burlington has about 3500 people max at
any given no 35,000 right 35,000 yeah
sorry that's what I thought I was like
my bad 5,000 that's it
yeah that's all I thought it was like
two and 50k damn no Vermont is to
250,000 people in the state of Vermont
no I know Laurie okay it's something
like this it's not that small its tiny
dude well it's a I mean it's a big issue
eight well there's Vermont 623,000 air
we go as population of Burlington is 42
K well I just guess so yeah that's crazy
that it's that it's yeah yeah there's
less people in Vermont than there are in
San Francisco and seven square in seven
square miles exactly it's kind of mind
blowing and you can really feel like the
smallness when you're there this is your
hood man I mean Vermont's right here on
Burlington's right on what is this lake
called Lake Champlain Lake Champlain
yeah
this on NDI and they are getting it I
don't yeah yeah okay so what's
interesting about this is Burlington you
know you would think that it was not so
close to Montreal but it's no it's right
there it's right there it's right yeah
yeah Burlington's like a stop to mantra
Montreal that's actually why Burlington
really works as like a place city yeah
it is still a city despite its smallness
and the reason it works is because it's
in between Boston and Montreal in New
York and Montreal yeah and that's the
reason it has it's like a waypoint it's
been a waypoint for like travelers and
like there's a big music scene and it's
surprisingly like mm-hmm prolific and
like legit they built that filing
cabinet what they were like [ __ ] your
corporate is that way yeah yeah yeah
exactly that's very cool city if you do
that there's a lot of really great
people in Burlington and a lot of really
great ideas and the way I saw it when I
was there and the way I still see it is
it's a really good incubator and that's
at least how I used it and how I wanted
to see it it's a great place to like
grow and be independent but like it's
very hard for things to leave the town
it takes something that's truly like
tremendous to actually like break out of
Burlington and into the rest of the
world and there are even things that are
just like so awesome and epic and some
bands that are like still chillin in
Burlington that it's it's gonna be it
takes like a move to New York to like
actually like go and flourish as like an
artist or a band absolutely in a city of
42 K there's yeah and there's no
breakthroughs compared to New York or
Montreal or Boston yeah nothing quite
like that
were you there 25 years 25 oh no
actually Burlington is just where I went
to college so I went up there for I went
up there you know as a college freshman
and I University of Vermont
yeah University of Vermont and I stayed
there you know for an extra three years
or so so I was only there for about
seven years but it's a place that can
really library before that I was in I
was in Connecticut
place my hometown was Windsor and so I
lived there I lived in field basically
just a bunch of subsidiary towns like
around Hartford like suburbs of Hartford
which is the state's time there were 17
18 and then to Dan yeah I got the hell
out of there it's like seven years in
Burlington yeah
and they were great they were great
seven years no no no tell me a bit about
your use where how did you figure out
that art filmmaking photos how did you
figure out that this is which cared
about well the earliest things that I
was that I noticed myself being good at
were math and were you know like art
just creating stuff I was always like
jot down ideas drawing the first thing
was drawing I guess and you know pons
suggestion from my mom she was like well
you're good at art you're good at math
so why don't you like try and be an
architect or something like that I was
like okay I like art I was always
building blocks building Legos I was
like okay so I'll start thinking about
design and how to build something so you
would have probably been a good
architect thank you thank you I would
have I would still enjoy to be an
architect but me too it was something
about the education system that
eventually it was something about like
high school and just like I don't know
it's there was a disconnect there
especially with me like I guess I mean I
was diagnosed with ADHD with a very from
a very early age which I still question
whether yeah that's not a disease of any
sort of disorder it just means you're
not buying the [ __ ] I don't know
exactly
time for the crap and yeah yes I ADHD my
ass precisely well that's what the thing
I was gonna mention next and but because
of that diagnosis you know it was like
the mid 90s early 2000s you know I was
shuffled off into like another room
sometimes other classes and they were
like you know and you know I had to take
medication and I was just like this
system sucks I really hate this I really
hate learning this way and so the only
access I really had to learn math from
was that system and I was just like I
want nothing to do with this I don't
think this is an efficient way to teach
people let alone me
and yeah any people at all and I still
don't think it's a good way schools and
I mean I went to a good one I'm very
grateful for the school I went to you
had to get him by lottery they pulled
from a bunch of different towns is very
like kind of experimental type of
education we're like version 10 yeah 100
version education systems yeah if a lot
of room for improvement yeah and it
moves very slow anything legislative and
having to do with the government it just
moves too too slow for the modern age
you know we can we can keep up with the
VRA our cryptocurrencies biotechs
blockchains have you been on a
government website lately
be careful be careful don't talk about
the government I'm sorry but uh yeah for
its multi trillion dollars better yeah
can do a lot better why can't we just
vote on yes as a child yeah yeah yeah I
digress so I just want nothing to do
with learning things that way so art was
the thing that I wanted to do when I got
home so I played guitar I liked played a
lot of video games actually I took in I
watched a lot of movies watched a lot of
TV I was always taken in because I was
putting out drawing and taking taking
photos and stuff like that and that was
just my extracurricular I was like mine
those were my hobbies and they developed
naturally quicker than the things I was
learning in school so so it's like art
arts the thing I'm good at you know so
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna try and do my
best and be my best at it how long do
you what hold were you when you picked
up the guitar um I think my mom's put me
in guitar lessons when I was about nine
something like that but I really didn't
take that out to Paul's mom yeah yeah
big shout out to mom love you
what's mom's name Sandra Sandra
Rogers said you're all that no Yuri ah
no Rogers Yuri ah no Rogers can we get
around the phone
can we get Santa on the phone I'm not
gonna call what I can do from knowing
you knowing nothing about you except one
fact thank you for putting Paul into
guitar lesson so he was nine thank you
and for birthing him into the world
amazing yeah I know raising him and
nurturing his soul so we can call it
that guitar at nine is good that's a
good start guitar lessons especially
yeah but once again I really didn't take
to them I didn't practice actively and I
didn't what I didn't realize that he was
just me breaking through like a learning
curve I was really frustrated about
until about like freshman sophomore year
of college when I really started like
actively I just kind of clicked I like
figured it out I was like oh it actually
had good question before we get there
yeah what were you watching you we're
talking about watching all of these
films and stuff what were you watching
because how the [ __ ] do you get this I
you know you're capturing stuff in 2018
but you're also you have this edge from
like 1960 at the same time yeah a lot of
old a lot of old stuff and I guess
that's true with my with the music that
I listen to as well a lot of my tastes
come from my you know my parents they
were like they were nerds they met at a
video store
yeah yeah right
so it's just like I'm what was the video
store called back then oh boy which one
was it I think it might have just been a
blockbuster I think my mom was managing
a blockbuster gosh back then that was
like the that was like the Apple back
then you know yeah it's something like
they deal back that blockbuster was yeah
for sure now yeah exactly that was the
way you acquired media you know and
people loved you know back then though
brand-new was going and renting a VHS
tape yeah [ __ ] big deal man we would
make a whole trip out to the
to the store to go rent a VHS cassette
you would like oh you would like get a
stack for the whole week these five
movies will get me through the week and
if you if you watch them all like if you
had maybe one too many double feature
nights or whatever then you just had to
watch them again the same way we go on
YouTube for two hours at the end of this
night we now we back then there wasn't
no yeah access to that like that so that
we just we would pick those movies
what was that picture there hold on
standby yeah what's up with that yeah
yeah teach us about this I mean how you
do this this was on my cell phone
actually please I took this one on my
cell phone
it is either a filter on it I mean would
a little bit a little bit of galaxy s 9
you shout out to Samsung still having
the best cameras on phones [ __ ] no I'm
not gonna say just pulled the s9 card
yeah yeah didn't think you pulled the s9
card on us damn okay cool
all right but so well I had an s5 before
this and I was completely enamored with
that camera what I realized is that I
needed to have a good camera on me at
all times
and so the best way to do that was
obviously with a nice phone say what the
s no no the best camera no but so this
was through a also on the end sometimes
I noticed and I guess that's a nudie
line in San Francisco it's like a light
rail transit line yeah and so this is on
the on the wall and there was just all
smeared on the wall and I like to take
pictures like through odd panes of glass
or like through with like an additional
layer you know so there's the lens and
then there's the weird then there's a
window or there's a mirror or there's
like a reflection and then or a puddle
and then I take the picture through that
so it kind of like you know gives it a
look and so this there's just [ __ ]
the story you shoot it as a like a blur
like
yeah yeah yeah sometimes there's just
like no discernible image per se you
know it's just abstract but there was
just some oil smeared on the wall of the
end for some reason I don't know why I
can show you why Paul has this he has
this instinct to rather than make the
photo his instinct is I want to put
another layer before the photo yeah yeah
yeah and that's really unique again is
people don't think about oh how can I
add a layer before the photo to make a
unique that's yeah that in itself is
very unique and interesting thank you
yeah it's just something I've always had
an inkling to do I don't know because
it's unique it's different and you know
what when I was looking at this I was
like you know Paul oh let could start
his own filter company for photos yeah
you know if you just sell oil orioles
smeared black whale smears one what was
the other one puddle like a puddle a
puddle yeah you know yeah I've taken a
lot of those um this IP is officially no
go make this into the world people
please yeah go take pictures and cuddles
what can't is it this camera no whatever
you want yeah go ahead take pictures in
puddles like do it and then definitely
stomp around in those puddles like a
little kid okay so it seems as though a
lot of the the background to you is
exposure to able to have your own
creativity explored yeah yeah I guess
like so I guess actualization just like
yeah anybody else it's just about like
just trying to further yourself with
everything you know it kind of it weirds
me out sometimes like to see artists
that find and solidify a style and and
can do that their whole lives and and
never break out of it per se and it's
not a negative thing or a positive thing
and some some days I'm envious of it but
for me it's hard for me to like I land
on a thing and I try it and I feel like
I've become
comfortable with it not to like a point
of like mastery or anything but
developing a intense comfort with a
certain mode of making things and then
I'm like next next you know there's no
need to dwell on it for so long I don't
think cuz I guess what might separate me
from other artists per se is that it's
more about the idea being communicated
than necessarily the making of art
itself whether it sound a certain way or
look a certain way you know just kind of
communicating something and being done
with it when it's done being said no no
reason not to beat a dead horse I guess
okay now there's something that I want
to EE think is really pressing here you
made a move from yes Burlington to San
Francisco so that move is a powerful
move yeah don't cook a while yeah and
and just the sheer amount of of powerful
nodes that you ended up moving yourself
to yeah yeah so anyway we talk about
that a lot on the show is network theory
of nodes and influence and power lot of
people in this town so a lot of people
and not just Abel it's the amount of
influence that those people have that -
and there's also our most tech companies
in the world a lot of them are in the
Bay Area yeah yeah and also I mean it
has to do there's a particular magic in
the air here it's not even it was he it
was here before the city was built you
know it was your boob way no good or
yeah exactly yeah there's that magic
been here for a while
I mean it made whatever it was made a
bunch of people go hmm
they they saw a bunch of sand dunes and
they were like let's build an entire
city on this which the city will
literally build the next 150 years of
civilization
yeah well this and many others however I
mean unless it gets unless the sea
levels rise too much in which case like
36 hours not thinking about those
catastrophes that are on their way
inevitable sea Rises
hurricanes and earthquakes and Yosemite
blowing up yeah it's hard to of stone
you had to bring it up oh my god yeah
right I mean it's it's tough to rely on
this city being here another 100 200
years you know I mean not to say that
it's not going to be but it's hard to
say for sure that it's going to be you
know I guess that's true of anything but
especially when all the artists come
like you and take out all the techies
you know the you you laugh right now
right yeah you know with the trans women
with the automation transition yeah you
never know artists maybe the next
engineers well communication is always
important it's fun even next whatever
glad coming back into style or whatever
yeah all right yeah you're gonna do it
man you're gonna make a flat back so you
so you made the move I want to know why
you made the move um well it's once I
guess we touched upon it earlier in many
ways there's a there's a lot of reasons
but one of the main reasons is that in
the town that is Burlington as beautiful
as it is and as wonderful as all the
people are incredibly nice people
Vermont is like one of the kindest
states in the Union like there it's when
the happy it actually just took over
Hawaii as the happiest state in the
entire United States that way about
Vermont I've been to Vermont you know
I'm from back east and I just there was
a certain pleasantness that it was an
energy that was you know you felt you
sensed these these are good people here
their heart is in the right place you
know I'm glad you had that you know in
here you know you had it in you to
develop that within yourself and you
know now well the San Francisco
California [ __ ] you know I'm saying
exactly totally opposite so yeah well
yeah there's there's definitely I mean
the people here are friendly and they're
in their own
as well they're just no I mean it's not
like it's not like Vermont because I
guess with Vermont - there's probably
like a mutually assured discomfort come
the winter so everybody has a lot of
respect for one another just for I guess
literally surviving in Vermont six
months of freezing cold temperatures
yeah sometimes seven just like you know
so we're not dying where did that rink
winter list of reasons to move together
that way it shifts between number one
and number two
yeah it's funny cuz similarly for me
it's like Network effect and getting
away from six months of freezing cold
temperatures in South Dakota and
Minnesota yeah you're like so close to
each other no way no how
never again I was like I was like okay
one more winter and then I'm going
anywhere towards the equator baby yeah
it's funny so San Francisco is actually
the challenge mode for me San Francisco
was the harder of the two options I had
really like mold to mold down because I
whittled it down from Boston
Philadelphia New York and San Francisco
interesting because the other ones were
all really close to where you are
exactly and it's cool that you pulled
the big leap yes for sure
I felt like I felt like you know I had
the really difficult because San
Francisco is very expensive so it's hard
to save up the money and it's very far
so that's an additional cost and then
also like just all the effort to but it
also presented a really awesome
opportunity to move far and to
experience that entire move so I didn't
physically I shipped my stuff and then I
took I took the Train yeah on over a
combination of going down to I went down
a Harrisburg for a film festival with I
was just a rideshare I found on
Craigslist actually and then I took my
stuff I shipped it and
came via train to the Amtrak
yeah via Amtrak to Emeryville and then
of course at bust in San Francisco then
my stuff arrived like a week later yeah
so I'm so grateful for prescient curly
how did because he introduced us big
shout-out to Preston yeah we like Christ
a huge shout out yeah we love you
Preston I think I deleted him that when
I found out he was a trump supporter oh
that's finally thing on Facebook ya know
if they're Trump Sports he just sees
that the that's right it was just a bad
day you know I just went to the side
thing I don't even want you know just
the like it's not so he seems you know
like a Bernie guy to me he's probably a
guy to be grudgingly vote for Bernie
from Vermont from Burlington you know my
theory on it happens is they kind of
yeah yeah yeah she's good too yes we
have we have we slept so much to talk
about a way of annuity yeah thank you
press and show Hugh shot at you now okay
yes please yes enjoy enjoy for a moment
I see what I'm talking about like who
makes content like this a 2019 you know
yeah this is your you're at you're at a
uniqueness level of 9000 it's amazing
thank you yeah I have a tough time
parsing together the things I make
sometime like why did I do this I just
didn't feel an energy and I just kind of
try and go with it you're my inspiration
you know what the beginning of our
videos now you were talking about like
you get better and better at doing
something live you know got better at
premiere so I started to take the
segment's from the show from the
interview and I threw them at the
beginning and I made it black and white
yeah it like a flash forward yeah yeah
and so I was just thinking about you
know you should teach me how to make the
the things like so that it looks like
the flash-forward has at least a little
bit of like a real thing going on yeah
anyway we'll talk about that later you
can do that with some overlays and stuff
but this is real fills that's why it
looks like that that's what I'm saying
there's ways to digitally do this but
this guy's doing it
yeah not quite this stuff - one of the
reasons I like the Bolex is is that they
have their own like fingerprint every
one is different because they were all
made like at least even the newest
models were made at least like 30 40
years ago bo w ve Bo Bo le ex bollocks
and so interesting so so there's this is
this what it looks like what what are
you looking at it's coming up is this
what it looks like man whoa yeah
that's the camera I use essentially whoa
hahaha it's not is that an old ad or is
that how much they cost
it depends on which ones you want to get
mine are so that was roughly similar to
that ones basically the one I used to
make those now I have two different ones
the one I was using at the time was
essentially one I absconded from UVM and
I was just using that for a hot second
like I just kind of had that until I
returned to course where I love and of
course you know one needed it
no one asked about it no one cared no
one cared that they had this gem of a
thing yeah look at that that's great
god this is gorgeous yeah I'll just yeah
let's just look at him how can you not
be in spotty but we tangent again the
pulse Paul's very Polymathic and so
we're we're gonna end up tangent you
know that touch that ADHD I guess it's
well you you're 22.0 sitting in chairs I
think that's essentially what an ADHD
diagnosis means it's like oh you
probably aren't you've know stuff you
like a bunch of different stuff the
beginning of the show is gonna say that
great minds think alike okay all we need
to talk about this all right what is
going on with the evolution of art and
distribution of art and multi
yeah yeah it's been crazy
it went from you would only be able to
have a tangible analog copy of something
yeah - now when it's digitized everyone
in the world can have like next next new
save next save - collection you've got
collections on Facebook
you've got collections on Instagram
you've got collections on your phone
you've got collections on microSD cards
so you can plug into anything you've got
stuff stored on ITV's you know or Apple
TVs or whatever on the cloud on your
Smart TV and Chromebooks or what and you
know I don't know it's is that does
anyone have Chromebooks I don't know
your students definitely do tablets you
know it's everywhere and you own it's
people own everything and they own
nothing you know what I mean because one
of the things it's I you know people are
really protective of their art these
days they put like watermarks on it and
all this stuff and I just don't really
care it's like whatever it belongs to
the world and also there's so much of it
nobody cares
every single individual that's one of
the reasons I like to shift around to me
like one of the things a friend of mine
said to me recently you know I was
trying to like rearrange my Instagram my
website and he was just like well you
know man
no one's looking as close as you are and
I was like you know you're right not a
single person that's paying as much
attention to you as you are and so
that's kind of why I just put so much
out there in hopes that I've got it you
know people will put less stuff on your
website it's like I could I could pare
it down well I kind of want there to be
if someone wants to spend a whole day
looking at my stuff if they feel so
compelled I kind of wanted the it to be
there I really want to spend them I
don't know if they want to really put in
the effort who's - well Who am I to deny
them no I don't expect anybody to do so
but I would like somebody to do so and
hopefully it'll find one somebody one
day then it will really affect that's
right you know just like I know it's
happened to me where I find somebody
Bandcamp and they're not really
well-known
and I'm just like you are one of the
greatest musicians I've ever heard and
you're just like this nobody on Bandcamp
and you're well yet anyway you're
somebody to me and you know you download
the album you listen to it and you just
hope that maybe one day they find the
rest of their audience or their
successor you know I guess we're all
just trying to live good life good good
lives and for me creativity and creating
things I'm putting them out there in the
world is essential in that and that's
the only thing I really know for sure
right now and if there's something
that's going to click into place for me
like my place or my niche creatively and
it'll just click as so long as I keep
putting my stuff out there yeah you
point towards the importance of having a
content library yes exactly the backlog
is essential it's so essential so
essential when you only have one or two
or even a hundred pieces of content
interestingly enough you become more
difficult to discover yeah yeah become
easier to discover with more contact
yeah and people can say oh whoa I didn't
know that he had 20 pieces of content in
this category yeah instead of just one
yeah they go to the website from your
Instagram they think you're a
photographer or they think you're just a
musician or they think you're just this
or just that and they're like oh those
other things he directs a film he he
works with this company's the head
designer or photographer for whatever
you know oh look at all the rest of the
work I have oh and the products too and
I like that company now and all these
change to different things you know they
do and I guess the thing that people are
coming to term did people are coming to
terms with on social media and and on
like you know the main platforms that we
distribute art like Vimeo Facebook
YouTube all these things Instagram and
there I think people are coming to terms
right now with their lack of overall
importance on and individuality and this
just mostly homogenous stream of
information right and that's one that
there's no place to discover people that
only have 300 or less followers yeah
that's one that they I really don't like
the way the algorithms are working these
days where they only want you to see
things that a bunch of people are
looking at as opposed to things that
nobody's looking at there's no reverse
there's no there's no Instagram there's
no social media platform where you see
the things that nobody is seeing you
know there's no there's also partially a
reason why that is right well yeah
there's partially a reason why well
there's a lot of reasons yeah that is
it's just why is there no reason to
switch it that's the thing why is there
no reason to have the option yeah it
would need to be partially based on
giving people opportunities to showcase
themselves in a greater spotlight
so the algorithm could then pull someone
that has a less of a follower account
into news feeds to see how well it does
you used to be that's great yeah thank
you Ron
so yeah that's it's it's this is only
the beginning of this conversation but
yeah I want to yet continue talking
about this because I have some questions
for you at the end but please
continually are the real death the real
the real like like
the this is it's like the the before and
after is the chronological
newsfeed I think on Instagram there's
there it was my aunt discovered things
from 15 days ago or from yeah yeah it
used to be such that you saw as it was
being released you know it's like this
was three hours ago this was five hours
you know you got to see the whole day
and I really liked seeing the world that
way it's like oh this is what the
morning looked like somewhere this is
what the but now it's like it's it it's
devolved into this weird like like
hashtag contest you know where it has
nothing to do with the content where it
feels like it's really not oh you know
it felt like it used to be about to
content because there was this fairly
unbiased way of seeing it you know if
you followed somebody and they posted
something at a certain time you saw that
and you saw when they posted it you know
and you got to see you looked at it at
2:00 and you saw things that were
just released at 2 or 1 or whatever and
so that gave things at least a chance to
be their own content whereas now it's
like I follow somebody with 600
followers and I follow somebody with
14,000 I'm going to see the content from
the 14,000 follower 1 and rarely no
matter how much I engage with the 601 am
I going to see their content you know no
matter how much they like my stuff and
how much I like their stuff is that are
you sure about that because I think if
you go and like them they like you if
you follow each other and then you go
comment on each other stuff you you will
see it but it only lasts like a day and
a half you know and it completely wears
away when the engagement is not
necessarily there and it used to be such
that you kind of so if you followed them
you saw their content and now it seems
like it's less that way now it seems
like why am i why am I seeing so much
content from this person that is like
more of a tangent to my interests
whereas now you know it's like it
followed six hundred people or whatever
let me ask you this question yeah what
would your ideal design of an artist
discovery platform look like oh boy I
don't know I don't design them generally
but give me a general principle or two
that you think would be important
[Music]
um I guess that's a really tough
question I've never been asked that well
you know your boys got those good
questions I know I know if I should have
prepared more what would it look like I
really don't know I think we have some
pretty good ones right now it's just
they have problems and I'd like to see I
guess one of the things I'd like to see
is regardless of it being any one
specific platform you know the
Internet's kind of becoming like TV and
social media is kind of becoming like
the channels that you use it's right so
right now every single platform it
doesn't want to be the channel it wants
to be the TV it wants to be all of your
channels and it just can't work that way
and I think there's going to be research
there's gonna be a wave where there's a
lot of minor like more niche based
boutique social media platforms for
specific kinds of creator and in
specific genres so you'll have your goth
rock one and you'll have your then
you'll have your you know I don't know
you'll have your Polaroid only one or
whatever and it's not going to be like
so like reddit wants to be the entire TV
you've got are you've got are all of
those things but it's the way that that
you engage with that that makes it
ineffective for certain things and more
effective for other things and so
there's going to need to be things that
come in and fill in the blanks and those
things need to be allowed into the
market and right now it's so saturated
and especially the way I guess the
economy works so I'm no expert on that
it seems like there's no room and no
money flowing to those small things to
like come up there I see ads sometimes a
lot of the attention economy is
saturated with incumbency there you go
exactly yeah yeah I know for sure much
like our government I'm gonna get in
trouble we're gonna get in trouble no
it's really refreshing seeing some young
people get into Congress yeah let me
know how that works out for everybody
engineers artists
okay I vote your problems away yeah I
want to vote for me for president you
brought something really interesting to
attention which was that every channel
wants to be a TV yeah that was very
funny that you said that because
Facebook's trying to take all of your
attention
YouTube's trying to take all of your
attention that's the same people own a
lot of the - you know it's like why do
you need to get all of everybody and all
like the rest and they're kind of
looking exactly the same - it's like I
go on a story here in a story here now
let's look at hosts into the feed yeah
yesterday made a post into our YouTube
channel
yeah into the news feed of the channel
with like another that exists there's
like a community feed for your
subscribers in it I hate that that's
awful why am i yeah and they're all
trying to expand and take up so much of
the market and so much of these things
are failing so bad like one of the few
it's like everything every new thing
they want to be successful like
Instagram stories you know Instagram
stories are great I love them they're
like the snapchat killer the particular
I mean vine was already dead but it that
it like really put the nail in the
coffin if you see Twitter stories which
we kind of already do it so much I don't
I don't actually use Twitter because I
hate Twitter I have yeah I hate that so
Matt of commute we don't we don't really
don't we learn to be careful you guys
are supposed to know these are good
things are saying all right I want to
ask you what is the because you were
touching on this a little bit earlier
you were talking about the future of
distribution and art being the sort of
boutique sort of artisanal curations
yeah it's like you'll pay like three but
it's say that real TV channels are
trying to do this right now but it
doesn't work because their TV channels
their programs don't that their their
content doesn't transfer in that way
because it's still designed it still has
breaks for commercials you know it's
still designed for a television format
and it just can't work that way you know
but you see things more successfully
that used to be like I don't know like
crunchyroll or whatever used to be
something that was you'd go on for free
and it would be mostly like illegally
put up content you know and somehow now
they've transferred over to being like a
legitimate streaming platform that kind
of thing
it's like the content needs to come from
the internet not come from the TV to the
internet so you know one of my favorite
ones is boomerang I actually they have a
decent streaming service and I like that
you can watch like old cartoons the same
with Adult Swim but it just kind of
seems like they're those things aren't
transferring in the way that I don't
know it's just not it's not working
there's a disconnect TV not internet you
know there's a it's a certain format
like you know why is your stuff still 30
minutes
you know why is your stuff still 45 to
an hour it's like that's designed for a
different mode of consuming with the
internet it's random you know with the
internet you're like you're looking at
an image then you see a minute long
video then you see a 30 second video
then you're watching a whole episode
then you're back to looking at a ton of
images it's like you need all the
content and only like a specific
specific kind of vein of the content
sometimes I don't know yeah it's hard to
yeah I'm really happy that you're
starting to talk about all this because
it's stirring up a lot of important
conversations that hopefully we will
have on the program soon yeah because
the more that we talk about the future
of attention economics of social media
and distribution and art is all very
fascinating conversation I want to ask
you what is the most profound artistic
epiphany that you've had that I've had
the most profound one I think this about
a lot of things it's once you get to a
certain like level once you get above
like a certain bar then it's like
they're they're all the same
you know because so many people like
debate you know who's the best filmmaker
who's the best artist and there's a line
where like
you just like reached that and you pass
it you're just like okay I'm one the
best you know everything everything is
number one past that point so what's the
best epiphany I've ever had I don't know
there's some that fit into that category
but a revelation I'm not I'm not sure I
guess
I guess some of my formative ones were
probably in listening to like Pink Floyd
in my youth I really loved Pink Floyd
they're one of my favorite bands
probably one of my favorite like
artistic collaborative efforts ever in
in all of like probably one of the most
influential things on me actually is
Pink Floyd and in all it's in everything
that it is whether it be like the films
that accompany it during their live
shows or the light shows or their the
way they perform the music itself the
lyrics the album covers one of the
things that clicked when I was listening
to them I really loved their album art
and then I realized that they had a
company and specifically an art director
curating everything and that was Storm
Thorgerson he did all their album
artwork and he did a lot of their can
you call some to work up maybe because
it actually is very oh no the the I was
always intrigued by the the characters
that were [ __ ]
it was an actual [ __ ] Wow yeah
there's Gerald Scarfe drawing all that
okay yeah we're running out of time okay
okay let's let me Paul your incredible
human being that's great he's one of the
realize East High alright wise he's high
art he's high fine wonderful Preston's I
know you two will really like each other
and yeah it so happened to be that we
really like each other yeah yeah so um
Paul what do you mean by that
you'll see anyway
all right okay you made you made one
reference to the first part of your of
your comments about profound epiphany
please tell the viewers teach us right
now where is that threshold for you when
you break through and then you're like
oh everyone up here is like number one
you know oh I don't
it depends all subjective you know
everybody's got that everybody's got
their own like way of like gauging and
judging and I don't know oh I guess you
know I used to UM I used to have like
really concrete definitions of it and I
don't really adhere to those anymore but
those used to be like say for instance
with a musician if you could on your
instrument or whatever like really kind
of adapt yourself to any context and any
style like that really got you into it
like that place for me so there's
certain markers but there's no real like
defining characteristic but for me
there's just I don't know there's a
sweet spot that certain artists hit
where their aesthetic and their their
mastery over whatever it is that they
whether they make images or they make
music or whatever their mastery of it
combined with the things they're trying
to communicate really just like hit it
right here for you and you're just like
that is a completely new way of looking
at it and I've never thought of it that
way and thank you so much for showing me
that that and thank you you know it's
just like it's just something good art
connects you to everything good art is
really it's it's very spiritual when you
can like really you can when I watch a
really good film I feel a connection to
all of the human race you know what I
mean it's just all working together and
I'm just like I'm just in it and I'm
feeling it I guess with our onee if you
know a couple of couple your favorite
films like of all the films you know
that's good that you go back to Pink
Floyd and now you know you go back
before your time you know are there any
you know older films that you know
had impact on you older films so some of
my earliest some I'll list off a few at
some honorable mentions
so with favorites it's tough for me like
people are like what's your favorite
film like I know I understand yeah but
there are certain ones that you know
influenced you and more than others you
know anyway somehow so so I guess some
of the most influential films on me
recently and some of the most
influential films on me and making
things that you're seeing here on this
screen are probably there's Alice or
alengka which is a Czech version of
Alice in Wonderland by a filmmaker
called yon spank Meyer and he's one of
the greats he's one the greatest
animators that's ever lived and he got
me onto the whole 16-millimeter thing
because he was doing everything on
sixteen millimeter there's also daisies
which is an essential film of the Czech
black wave or I think it's polish
actually so it would be wrong to call it
check but it's part of that movement it
really does feel it's like very similar
or polish black wave whatever it's a
good film and Apocalypse Now had a big
influence on me
Brazil is one of my favorite films
Koyaanisqatsi which is almost entirely
time-lapse and scored by Philip Glass
amazing film and in fact all the films
in that series done by godfrey reggio
and Ron Fricke are excellent films
samsara was done by that cinematographer
Ron Fricke this is totally out of my
league these films I've never heard lots
I have heard of yeah the most beautiful
movies I've ever seen in my life
yeah isn't it that's a profound
experience rolled into a film please
let's stay on that for a moment as we on
this notion of this profound spiritual
experience that someone made art that
was so connecting and just first into
your soul and again increase your
awareness that is your description yes
art well art is I guess even more
condensed than that the the main
definition I have for art is sacred
communication I love that great words
for it say two words sacred
communication it's just yeah it's
community it's something someone's
trying to communicate something and it's
so profound and complex that you put it
on the altar of sacred Adi I mean you
see it in the way we talk about like oh
he's my idol he's a god or she or they
they're they're a god with the camera
with a guitar on the piano they're my
they're my poets they're they're my
poetry idol you know what are we talking
about how this is being under attack and
that's another thing you talk about
sacredness and that's and I was saying
that our crime is f4 it's a good point
yeah yeah their honor the fact that you
call art sacred communication and art
has been so long and dumb that [ __ ] down
they want pretty everyone's always
attacking one another everyone's sake
Rinna D is always under attack from
someone else's idea of what yeah you
know I hear people they're like they're
I give them that definition they're like
well be careful cuz that gives it like a
religious context and I'm like well is
it not is religion not steeped religions
are just giant multimedia pieces of art
[Laughter]
they just happen to have big I mean like
what the foot you walk into a church
like what else is that like other than a
giant collaborative piece of art you
have stories that you tell you've got a
special stage you've got a special
speaker you've got special windows
you've got special architectural books
special books special rules
special rules that's all it's just a big
art piece you're just like it's like you
know people get into fights over whether
or not like their favorite movie is
better than the other person yeah yeah
people start wars over that [ __ ] nobody
started a war over a movie just yet to
my knowledge but I think obviously
people have been like obviously great
violent acts have been perpetrated over
films and over pieces of art another one
of my favorite makers Louie Boone well
when the original Surrealists you know
right up there with Dali and this [ __ ]
some of his some of his films back in
the day getting shown in Paris they
sparked riots people burning the theater
people throwing Molotov cocktails as the
[ __ ] movie theater on the opening
night just an anticipation of the film
that he was getting released that was
about to get released and I guess
another tangent to is where do we find
that in the modern day how do we find
something how do we find something that
someone's gonna care about so much that
I guess they like how do you turn a
photograph into something that people
are gonna like it's gonna spark such a
debate where people become violent not
that that's my end goal but it's like
that's the Signet that's a signifier of
an important idea people are so invested
yep that's a really beautiful way to
understand mimetics is can you make some
sort of art that is so creative and
thought-provoking that it gets so
virally shared because people have some
sort of like that controversy with the
color of the dress yeah because people
saw it different colors yeah yeah and so
but this would be more like how how
ridiculous is it that earth still hasn't
figured out how to work together as he
has one organism moving forward the
probably the biggest one I can think of
like that right now
is probably the whole thing with colin
kaepernick and like nike like you know
that's kind of an equivalent to that's
like people but people have mm-hmm and i
guess the the kneeling on the on the
football field it's not to get like two
political I guess those that's a thing
that really sparked it's such a simple
notion such a simple performance yes
simple performance yeah I always want to
see if people can either make a single
sort of item you're right that that
kneeling and whatnot is like a single
item but this sort of you know can you
design something that just goes out as a
digital asset and gets the whole world
thinking about why haven't we figured
out how to work together yeah okay it's
tough yes to get anything that reaches
the whole world well I don't think it's
even though we're soaking high yeah I am
eyes a lot you know that's one of those
important things if you're not moon
shotting then GTFO yeah yeah yeah you
know the saying shoot for the moon or
you land and you land amongst the stars
at least anyway but at least you know I
want you to play on the way out but I
want to ask you a couple quick questions
yeah okay do you think we're alone in
the cosmos Oh obviously not like the
whole universe no there's something else
it's like whether or not you know we've
been contacted or whatever it's just
like that's all just here saying so we
have the facts you know but no duh and
if we're if we are right now then
certainly we will not be forever it's
just the nature of like the odds are
against it it's an interesting if we are
recently won't be forever
no let's hope that we're not alone and
there's something other than us to come
in and save the day somehow only one way
to find out though those things so
things that are so in concrete like that
beautiful to speculate on but hard to of
course if you can't put your finger on
it you know then it's just a and it's
just a debate until it becomes like
confirmed so I think the same thing
about Ron said
we have to bring up sex in the show why
do you do that I'm gonna take you to
[ __ ] courts it's gonna be me against
Paul Spiegel and you're [ __ ] done do
you know what makes sense if it was you
against Paul okay
are we in a simulation
no no I don't think so I think this is
reality and it's just because it would
be tough to I don't know that's such a
complex apparatus that it must be
designed on though there once again
there's no way to tell and I guess we're
all in kind of our own simulation you
know especially if you think about the
way psychologically yeah
especially if you think about
psychologically the way our brain can
conjure up things that aren't
necessarily in those things then it's
like I mean if you think about that
feedback loop we're all in our own
little worlds so like it all right and
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world what do I think is
the most beautiful thing in the world in
this one the on the earth take it where
you want it um I don't know I don't know
most beautiful thing once again I guess
it has to do with that once you hit a
certain point like what they're all the
most beautiful things you know pass a
certain line there's some I guess you
brought that back that was good good to
do please
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world I can give you a few things that
are in that category um oh I don't know
I guess something simple I really like
sunsets yeah
stunningly beautiful ocean beach
probably one of the most beautiful
things in the world something about
water which actually you can see
throughout my work it's something that
I'm always fascinated by at the bending
of light that - very much not water yeah
sort of water sort of but the water I
guess just the nature that we can have a
particular consciousness where we get to
even indulge and enjoy these things yes
you know that's that to me is one of the
things I'm most thankful for you know
we're not like insects think thankfully
we're not I mean they have their own
very specific perceiving of things but -
super intelligence we are insects yeah
yeah yeah exactly but I mean who's to
say whether or not we have that
potential in ourselves that we just
haven't tapped into mm-hmm you know in
each individual a lot of people have
yeah I think I think so
I was talking to happen yeah I was
talking to somebody earlier today about
like a particular kind of like hearing
like he we were by the end and he was
just making conversation with me and he
was like well it's kind of weird that
that's really loud as a music I had my
guitar with me it's like as a musician
you know don't you do you think that
like you know such a loud sound hurts
your ears perhaps more than someone
else's that that maybe doesn't have the
trained ears and I'm like well I mean I
don't know necessarily what you mean by
the training I guess I can filter out a
loud sound near me and hear a sound far
away and work the muscle yeah exactly
it's just like anything else that's like
you'll see it's like oh well that that's
a very distinct ability that you must
have because you play a lot and I'm just
like no probably not just it must be I
think it's something that most people
have and it's just about knowing you
have it knowing how to tap into and use
it you reference mastery earlier you
know you're bringing it up yeah I'm very
big fan of mastery all right let's get
that yeah let's get that might get in
some take
eh-eh
oh when do you want me to start fun
let's um let's close out the show and
then we'll then we'll have you plate on
the way out like after okay it's gonna
be tough for me not that I'll just put
this right here I think if you've ever
dealt with a roomful of musicians that
all have instruments in their hands
that's like total chaos
some people think being like first grade
teachers it's like okay us but I would
say dealing with a roomful of
experienced musicians that are mature
adults that all have their instruments
is probably much harder it's just like
stop playing anything just stop it
please buddy actually I think it feels
more right how to have you play and then
close the show oh we're I'll take it
let's do it
I got no complaints tell us a little
also about what exactly is going on on
the guitar like what I do I guess so
this kind of style is either referred to
as new acoustic and it used to be
referred to as
American primitivism which obviously
fell out of favor because it's a little
bit condescending the American primitive
the idea was that you were adapting like
classical and like jazz styles to like
you know roots music like folk and blues
and stuff like that and so I had this
kind of ethnographic element very early
on in like the early 1900s all the way
to the 60s so it was like these
musicians mostly nerdy white boys were
finding like the playing of like you
know old-school backwoods blues
musicians like I think it's
I like Bukka white or something like
that and they were finding these
recordings of musicians that were either
old and dead and they were becoming
inspired by them and trying to revive
like folk styles but like giving it like
complexity and like you know what I mean
or a new form of complexity they had
their own
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are rad thank you very good thank
you man
it's a pleasure to do it so warming the
vibes are really strong I like a lot I
wanna I want to see if I want to see
does this harmonize with with the guitar
the mabini there's a bob we and finger
piano it depends it depends on what the
notes are tuned to
[Music]
[Music]
is it um yeah that was nice their first
definitely it works with me so I don't
know it day so each of these are tuned
to a particular key so I play in like
open tunings so it's like somewhat
restrictive and playing with other
people but the first so they're
obviously of course notes all along
these things that match you know quote
quote match um and it seems like yeah
you were doing a pretty good job of
paper deceased yeah it like locks
together
[Music]
[Music]
I like how there's an element of it's
like a dissonance
[Music]
oh that was fun I'm glad that we got to
mess around it than end a little yeah I
love this thing this is one of the best
I've had a few actually and this is one
the best ones that I've nubira plating
on Janos indeed watching this crush it
it's hard not to on these things
[Music]
[Music]
that's the Beastie Boys girls girls and
SS and has mister used in that song I
don't know what it sounds like a wind
chime but the upper row is so low it is
good it is really good it all it all
rings really it always really cool I
don't know it just makes it makes a good
sound each note is like really nice and
distinct on this one and the body is
really weird - usually they have a sound
hole like right here in the center but
this one is it actually doesn't even
have a sound hole this is the chunk and
there's a little bit of teacher that
teach about the sound hole for the
vibration what is yeah it would usually
be hollow I mean like the guitar it's
hollow and so then you gotta have space
for the sound to reverberate inside it
and then you have to have an exit for it
and this is this is just a hunk of wood
there's no Hollow yeah yeah I mean
there's hollowness throughout the wood
in its own way
that's why wood is good for acoustic
instruments and I guess acoustic
transmission of anything you know what
has you find that even without the the
NS ubiquitous yeah this one has a nice
ring to it even if you like mute the
times you know wood has a musical
quality to it just built in because
there's all these little chambers where
sound can build up and sound can be
communicated and
right throughout so but it's interesting
that there is no that there's no
hollowness to it quote unquote there's
no like body there's no chamber Paul
this has been so damn fun I've had such
a good time my man I'm so grateful that
you came on the show yeah likewise we
only started I know it feels like it was
it feels like a bunch of good tangents
like the whole conversation was a bunch
of like good little tidbits
yeah good tidbits exactly that's the
best we can do is is the tidbits yeah
you can't how do you communicate
someone's soul in an hour
Yeah right good luck yeah hard stuff so
and I hope you enjoyed the production
values of the show yeah Ron Vargas yeah
for technical directors there yeah yeah
yeah until they find out you can find
Ron Ron Vargas comm bagus with an R
market well this actually has like three
inches like everybody says I'm smart and
that Wallace okay okay alright so thank
you Paul thank you I'm really excited to
continue building concept with Paul
please go follow Paul his Instagram is
lit go check out his website links are
below also go and build the future go
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone go and make art go make music
go make film go create go build enough
sitting enough food consumption go and
get create build the future everyone can
love you thank you so much and peace
[Music]
[Music]
you